[Music]
well mike
look police officers sometimes make
mistakes okay
um they sometimes come on
give wait um police officers sometimes
make mistakes
for example this young lady
are you sure that's a police officer
this young lady
this officer of the law no this isn't a
u.s woman's soccer team
this is a police officer accidentally
left her gun in a bathroom can i just
correct you there
uh this officer left her
service weapon in a bathroom that's far
worse by the way that's where you could
lose a gun
yeah she lost her service weapon
well let's let's see i'm deanna cantrell
the police chief in san luis obispo
i talk i'm sorry i'm sorry i apologize
police chief the chief i'm deanna
cantrell
the police chief in san luis obispo i
talk about transparency and having a
relationship that's built on trust with
our community
so i also want to make sure i practice
what i believe therefore i think
you should hear this from me i was
eating lunch today at a local restaurant
in san luis obispo
and i went into the restroom even though
my gun was in a holster
it didn't stay clipped to my pants so i
removed it and i placed it next to me
i left and i left my firearm in the
restroom
within minutes i realized it but when i
went back it was gone
someone had stolen it i immediately
checked video footage
and i saw that three no no no no no did
somebody steal it
because stealing it would imply that
they broke into your car and took your
gun or
or yanked it off for you and ran away
you left your gun
somewhere yes it sounds to me like
somebody found a gun yeah nobody
if if i were to go to a bathroom and
there was a thousand dollars in cash
and i took it i didn't steal it
somebody left a thousand dollars in cash
and i took it because it was there
in the bathroom but when i went back it
was gone
someone had stolen it i immediately
checked video footage
and i saw that three people had entered
the restroom after me
the first man whose photo was released
on facebook
went into the restroom after me and then
immediately left the restaurant without
ordering any food
the next two people that entered the
restroom
were still in the restaurant and said
that the firearm was not in the restroom
when they went in
my actions were irresponsible and
dangerous
and i'm so grateful that after our
preliminary investigation
a child didn't find it i was complacent
and that's something you can never be
with a firearm so you're going to resign
so we need to outlaw firearms yeah um
secondly i love how they
how they plastered this guy without any
proof other than he went into the
restroom
they plastered this guy's face on
facebook a guy who very easily could
have just been using the rest yeah you
don't know nobody knows
i expect more for myself as a person and
especially as a police officer that has
carried a firearm for twitter do you
think her husband's disappointed
oh no royce what um
i don't think you think her husband's a
cop too because sometimes a lot of both
of them are cops
i think she's probably maybe single
maybe
yeah i hope she finds a dude she seems
nice like she made a mistake but hope
she finds a guy and gets married and
maybe has some kids i don't
think that's a priority for her right
now she seems like a
melissa etheridge fan like a real
career-driven type of woman
career driven lesbian bed death is real
folks yeah a lot of
a lot of heated up frozen dinners you
know what i mean
still first 25 years
this was reported to my supervisor and
law enforcement immediately
and the firearm was entered into believe
it or not is also a woman
this is a really [ __ ] up state i don't
want to go anywhere near this police
department
database so i handed it off to my female
police officer boss and she immediately
lost
that uh lost that report as well along
with her gun which is really weird
because she doesn't know what i went
into the bathroom so mine came back and
didn't have hers so if you've seen
two guns lying around please report
uh please turn them in to your local uh
police officer
the firearm was entered into a national
database now i'm off to stone creek
coffee to get my free coffee
go home to the bathroom
and steal my service weapon all right
thank you ladies
oh [ __ ] i expect to be held accountable
and i want to publicly apologize for my
carelessness
when i left the uh firearm in the
bathroom
the men's bathroom by the way because i
can use whichever one i choose oh boy
because this is america they said that a
man walked in and left with it so
probably was what a unisex bathroom is
what i'm assuming wherever she was
it had to be right yeah and i hope that
in some way this serves as a lesson for
others
no no no no no for others right
other people need to learn from her
mistakes
don't you love when you hear [ __ ]
lefties all the time only police
officers should have guns because
they're trained are you sure
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now you
are
the thing is look man lucy gun ask
anthony losing a gun's terrible
you don't know where a gun is it
disappears but
when you're a cop like i have confidence
i'm sure you do too
that's like day one academy stuff is
you don't you always know where your
service weapon is
no matter like that's number one no
matter what
you always know where your service
weapon is the squad car yes i'm not
kidding no it's for real they would
rather you lose a squad car than a gun
i'm telling you because if for some can
you imagine if that gun kills somebody
now
and it's found yeah i know and then when
they do they'll call for gun control
yeah exactly because you're a [ __ ]
idiot and you're irresponsible
it's almost like it's almost like a
certain group of people shouldn't be in
law enforcement
almost can't say that though but it's
almost like that